[Musique]
le petit monde du vélo à paris pour la
présentation du tour de france 2010 8
qui ne pourra accueillir les champions
cyclistes comme le français romain
bardet ou encore le vainqueur 2010 est
christopher fronde parmi les invités
deux délégations relief impatient de
découvrir le tracé sur écran géant
même si pour elle le secret est levé
depuis longtemps le 13 juillet c'est à
chartres que ça se passe il semblerait
que ce soit fougères à chartres à dans
ce que j'ai pu imaginer un sur sur le
tracé du tour de france et donc charte
serait une ville étape d'arrivée et
onfray l'arrivée comme les années
précédentes à savoir sur le dernier
kilomètre
avenue jean mermoz et ça devrait arriver
je pense par l'entrée de luisant pour
traverser la ville
[Musique]
grand départ de vendée le 7 juillet
c'était annoncé depuis longtemps on
avance on avance on avance jusqu'à la 7e
étape la plus longue du tour
231 km entre fougères et chartres le
lendemain jour de fête nationale
on reste en eure et loir
on s'est porté candidat pour depuis dix
ans pour avoir ce tour de france
christian prudhomme l'avait promis il
m'avait dit tu l'auras un jour départ ou
arrivée nous sommes la ville départ du
14 juillet ça va être une vraie fête de
bonnes infos c'est maintenant officiel
le tour 2008 passe en or et loire une
grande première pour dreux chartres a
déjà accueilli la grande boucle en 2004
et 2012
fougères chartres le 13 juillet dreux
avenir le 14 un véritable feu d'artifice
vélo cet été en centre val de loire